hello slugs this friday i will be in new
york city get tickets at estronize.com
and in february i'm coming to austin
i'm coming to austin texas captain
comedy club
stop it why can you do that on command
astronice.com sleepoverbyaster.com
thanks for your support you should hear
me queef
that was you queefing
what up sluggies you can come see me in
plano texas at the house of comedy
november 11th through 14th at the
punchline in philadelphia my hometown
please come see me bring me some cheese
sticks some wawa that's november 26-27
irvine one night at the improv december
2nd austin texas cap city comedy club
december 9th through 11th
the uh bananas comedy club in hasbro
kites new jersey december 16th through
18th milwaukee improv january 21st to
22nd a lot of other dates hit me up at
annieletterman.com
[Music]
are we gonna give each other's
temperatures up each other's
because i did not shave my butt
everybody's gonna check their own
temperature so we can see who's the
hottest
oh my god that's so good
i run cold for once maybe she won't be
the highest
oh my god it's our squid games
hi guys
this is the nurse's edition of trash
tuesday he says we're giving esther her
dream job red you're [ __ ] cheeks
open them wide use our ass tape bend
over dude stick it in your ass okay i'm
just scared like what if it comes out
brown i have lube upstairs you want me
to lube it up first yeah come get us
lubed can i go grab lube george and
instantly demonetized yes yeah i'll get
the lube later then okay wow stick
around guys keep some very interesting
content down the road hey guys you're
gonna see a weird intro later on in the
show and that's because we're protecting
you and our views
we're nurses now
clap your pants get your pants pots and
pants together guys because we are
everyday heroes nurses i think this
episode is truly a dedication to the
heroes of 2020 and 2021 i thought it was
about stolen valor myself um so this is
definitely stolen valor but we're going
to try and are we going to show your
sock together like it's uh
esther uh we need the defibrillator
quick my thermometer tastes good
like it feels good to chew is that the
one i put in my ass already
does it taste like battery acid i can't
help but feel like if this is the
nurse's episode perhaps the real nurse
should take it away i'm not a real nurse
you guys oh we were talking about donuts
oh okay we know you're not thank you
thank you no you're as close to a nurse
as uh we're gonna get
real nurses don't have time with for me
and esther you'd be scared we know we
try we've tried
you know the nurse we know i called her
accidentally i facetimed her by accident
the other day and i i facetimed her back
i was like hey [ __ ]
is she the nurse injector yeah that was
esther and my hot nurse that we met on
hike and runyon you guys have heard the
story but it never ceases to amaze me i
know we were walking at runyon canyon
and we said and i will put an emphasis
on walking very slowly everyone else was
hiking we saw the hottest girl there and
we were like let's go up to her and ask
her how to be hot like her we were like
this was our plan all we have to do is
find a hot girl ask her what to do and
literally she's like sure do you want to
come up to my apartment i live right
here and she brought us up she showed us
her tits immediately she got naked for
us
uh and then took us on a hike yeah and
there's but the and she made us wear um
weights on our ankles and we went and
bought weights we went to bigfoot five
and bought it tony henchcliffe there he
had gone to hot eight i remember this
whole day yeah that's what i wanted to
ask you esther you had two exes on joe
rogan the other day yes
one of them that was seven weeks ago
so you had ryan redman and toni
are we really gonna sat side by side
yeah in astronaut outfits yeah i don't
know why the boys like to do that duncan
does it oh there are certain guys my
favorite part about that though is after
your tweet you were like how many of
your ex-boyfriends are on the joe rogan
experience you're like for me it's two
and underneath you just see dave's
comment
cool yeah
cool
it's just weird that they were both on
together i'm like i just feel like for
dave who's like you know he's a very
successful guy
he's like i hope none of my colleagues
follow my yeah
it's definitely yeah
no comment but yeah
i love my exes i feel so
they're so it's so distant that there's
just nothing
left
i yeah i don't feel that way i don't
know about me or about
about my exercise you do feel like a
distant x yes
call an x right now
both of you you call an x you call an x
i thought this was the nurses episode
we're probably ex will i call
honestly it's like
i don't want to talk to any of them and
accidentally look at her she's doing it
i do anything i've been asked no i know
i'll do it after you i'll do one after
both of you
oh my god
i have one of my exes under they're only
on the phone under their nickname still
which is teeny peeny
should i do it should i do it
i'm not going to tell you who it is
until they pick up but you might know
from the nickname i don't know i look so
bad
[Laughter]
yeah but they follow you probably so
they know no but this lighting is worse
george
so embarrassing they don't like you he's
probably like with his new girlfriend
he's like i can't let her see how hot
esther was
why are you face timing that's a bold
move i was like i said just called
i'll do i'll do something all right he's
not answering
yeah because he's an exhauster
he has a big life to live
whoever's whoever gets to get their ex
to pick up gets to put a thermometer up
their chosen person's butt what if we
don't really want to do that oh i want
to do that okay um it's a big incentive
for me oh my god look whose phone number
just came up who can do it first and
whoever can get an x to answer
the game
all of my exes would answer call or
facetime prove it [ __ ] yeah
i don't want to talk to them
what am i what do i say i think i'm
calling one that will pick up okay hold
on i'm competing [ __ ] it's your turn i'm
competing
yes
nothing hey just i just wanted to say hi
and i'll call you later but um
that's all i just wanted to say i'll
call you in a bit
bye oh shady i need something to say to
this ex if i call you're on a hit
podcast come through kalila pull up i'll
call a second okay
you guys are losing this game right now
i don't want to talk to them no mine
suck
yours is going to sound cool oh second
next isn't it
all right i got one i'm gonna guys my
heart is beating it's making me sleepy i
know i feel crazy i'm doing it though
[Music]
no one's coming
hi you're on my podcast oh sweet let me
talk to
he's my friend we're having a
competition to see who can get their ex
to pick up the phone so thank you for
showing me that
you're good my exes don't have phones
unfortunately they're all in jail
thank you brian you know what actually
can i say something so this is brian
redman everyone
after we broke up i it was my 24th or
25th birthday and i had no friends and
brian even though we had broken up he
took me out to dinner and it was really
nice because you're hotter than him to
dominic's so thank you for being a good
person
oh my god we're flirting let me say hi
where's janice this isn't okay
hi brian don't give me eggs
he just stuck his tongue out of me he's
into me where's janice
does she want to beat esther
she's indoors does janice have um
jealous feelings towards esther no
i love janice no no way that's so sad no
it's because no we're cool i like janice
no janice is the best
but i'm teasing you
she's not threatened by you
thank you for picking up
definitely ok
annie not if it's going to cost you this
stress it seems like
she can't no she can't stop herself
she's got the dare the double dog dare
in her blood i do really have i know i
know you yeah but i'm like what do you
want
she can't control herself right now it's
best to just let her be
oh annie who is she calling you'll see
you guys own me for this oh my god annie
this is supposed to be this is making me
nervous i wanted to just
learn about nursing
well you can learn about
people needing to be helped
oh my god
i just called carlos
faked them out i faked them out
they wanted me to call one of my
ex-boyfriends but i don't like talking
to them so i called you as a joke do you
think carlos is in love with you still i
think carlos probably is like getting a
little bit of a chub thinking that i
pretended he was my ex we need
we need carlos in the studio that's how
much i don't want to talk to my exes but
you called carl all right i have to go
to work carlos are you a job carlos are
you attracted to annie who isn't i don't
want to go over this right now why not
because he's with do you want to eat her
butt
i did say it was perfect we do remember
that right that he said your butt was
perfect i i do feel like there is a
weird tension between you two no i think
it's like i like that people have
crushes on me
oh my god all right bye bye carl
esther what do you think of um
what they say
i don't know who they is but about
people who are friends with all of their
exes are um is a big red flag
really so you're actually on track
you're right i just feel like i used to
be very good friends with all my exes no
i can't defend this in two seconds i
think it's either a narcissist thing no
but this is
this is very easy that is people who are
like friends with friends like friends
like hang out talk this is more like if
i see you in the workplace we can have a
nice like hello there is a difference
and that i think is actually so good and
i'm proud of it now do i have that with
all my exes no my high school boyfriend
blocked my number
but but i still drive by every time i do
and i think in 10 years i think in 10
years annie will be friendly with all
those people i'm i'm friendly with them
now my body rejects them i want nothing
to do with them i don't want to be
friends with them i don't want anything
to do with them are you friends with
your exes duh she calls oh my god some
of them i could not be in the same room
with we would i would probably murder
them that's and that's a fact no i'm
friends with i'm close close friends
with two of my exes
best friends with one of them but it was
a very clear thing right up front where
it's like we're kindred we should have
stayed friends but we took it right we
took it there and that was a mistake but
we always knew we would get along and
probably be in each other's lives
forever um but there are a couple i i i
spit in their face if i saw them in
public i just you know what there's
something about like i feel like i've
grown so much and i've changed that i
don't even like
i don't
like shame who i used to be but the
things i put up with in relationships
are like really not in alignment with
who i am now yeah so it's like the
dynamic doesn't work like they're trying
to talk to me at a level that i don't
exist anymore and it just doesn't it's
just like it's a mismatch and i really
don't like when
like i've seen a couple guys that i
hooked up with in college and stuff or
when we called my friend matt like i
didn't like him talking about me
sexually from a lot like yeah that's
like news like i just i don't know i
guess people that know me
knew me and where i was like naked with
or whatever at some point it's like it
just feels like they've seen me and i
don't want to like that's exactly it so
two of the my exes that are really
really close friends with they would
they wouldn't dare
walk down memory lane with me they
wouldn't talk about me sexually they
wouldn't even say hey remember when we
did this they are living their lives
with their wives and children i am fully
respecting that they're fully respecting
me they don't they they would never dare
talk about me in a sexual way or even
think about it or even speak about it
with anyone it's like we just don't go
there done it we don't talk so old like
let me ask you something
are there any exes that either of you
have that you could ever in your wildest
imagination ever see maybe like just
just think about it could you ever like
yours years years from now
rekindle
absolutely not
i don't think i could either i mean
i'm not a backpedaler but here here's
what this article on vice says
narcissists and psychopaths love to stay
friends with their exes a new study
found that many people who befriend
their former lovers are narcissists and
psychopaths oh i believe it
it's like if you need if you feel the
need to just constantly still be in that
person's life in that way i loved like
my ex-boyfriend was like this where he
was always talking to all of his
ex-girlfriends and i didn't care because
i was like i just had been friends with
him so i knew he was like that but he
would always
like he would just be like saying i love
you to so many girls all the time jesus
he just needed to be like important in
their lives and i like
would never i just i think i'm his first
ex that would just never do that i would
never
and i think also i like did all this
work and then i got i'm like with
someone that's so healthy i did
something very narcissistic when i was
younger i think which was i only had sex
with virgin boys when i was a teenager
all the boys that i would have sex with
i made sure that they were virgins and
were you wearing the nurse outfit
could have been that's the only way it's
really bad can you explain though like
do you know more about why that makes
you a narcissist or a psychopath like i
get it but i want to know i think it's
having people around you like centered
that are centered around you like and
it's like pawns right they're like
playing with you well it's it's the need
to feel important in everybody's eyes
it's like they're still
the need to feel like you're still
center stage in somebody's life
and you still have that pull like even
if they're in a new relationship
what we had that kind of is is pretty
gross actually that's disgusting yeah i
had like like a boyfriend i would go to
when i would break up with other
boyfriends like an ex that i would
always go bang and i like the last time
i did it i was like i'm clinging to
something that's not like healthy i
don't relate to this person anymore it
was just like not like what i thought i
don't know and i just was like why do i
keep
this person and it was more like i think
of a nostalgia thing and arrested
development thing but it's like i just
onwards onwards and upwards look i feel
you there but i also like no regrets
either should we take each other's
temperatures oh yeah anally or orally i
do want to take it anyway but you were
going to get lube can you smell her wet
dogness
i love it i wouldn't give a [ __ ] i love
the smell of a wet dog
i thought you liked white [ __ ] god
annie that's like too graphic you want
to do the actual act but me saying it
but that's so great it's so explicit the
words that are the problem
that's lube oh i love what you have like
do you use that homemade for sexual
things and masturbation the journal
masturbation everything for on you
yeah because it's like it's better than
spit wait why do you need can i put it
in my vagina or does it have to go in my
butthole because i like to go like
clitoral with your hand yeah and it
feels so smooth up against it it feels
sometimes i get too much lube though
with clitoral stuff and it's like
i don't know i i need it to be a little
friction but i like this brand a lot
maybe we shouldn't um maybe they should
sponsor us first but we can blur it out
until they're ready can i smell it
wait that sounded so creepy
i want to smell everything you say
sounds crazy it shouldn't be sentimental
we should have the best i don't think
okay so question i'm a purist
i put it in my [ __ ] not in my vagina
because my asshole's
supposedly allegedly typing yeah well
would you wait why can you take your
temperature in your vagini
um you can take your temperature
anywhere okay hold on do you want me to
do it for you there's i i'm a little bit
not
like if i had just gone to your
appointment earlier
i would say maybe we should talk about
that um the girls went with me to get my
[ __ ] and actually emotional support it
took 30 seconds and then i would have
been in there for
they would have had meals they would
have had their lunch and their dinner
i have a serious question is there
something that's preventing you from
achieving your goals um esther you are
it is weird for the answer to be asking
you the question
what interferes with your happiness the
same answers are so annoying that i
think i need to get therapy
well i have the perfect source i have
the perfect option for you solution
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist i will i am
kidding about that but i will say better
help does help with that if you are
starting to get like annoyed with people
and agitated that's a you problem and
it's a really good time to go see uh a
counselor and no place better than
better help to do that right because
they have licensed professional
counselors who are specialized in family
conflicts
esther and i are related she's my dad
we're cousins but not just family
conflicts depression stress anxiety um
sleep trauma anger you name it i
probably have it and we all get help and
esther's faking it
no but there's no one out there that
doesn't need a little bit of help with
their mental health like that's just the
state of the world and the year and all
the things that we're dealing with on a
daily basis and life is better and
easier when you actually get help and
the great thing about better help is
that literally right from this moment
that you hear me say this you can be
communicating in under 48 hours with
someone that can help you feel better a
lot of people i think you teeter over
the idea and you think about it but it's
like if you're watching this right now
and you're having any sort of ruminating
thoughts or not feeling your best just
take the leap i mean we have a deal here
for you and just try it out also like
not to throw the older people under the
bus but we all have those people in our
lives who are a generation older who
don't believe in therapy they're not
helping you we are here to tell you the
three of us as users of this
it is it is real and you do need it and
we need it to you guys we want you to
start living a happier life today and as
a listener you'll get 10 percent off
your first month by visiting our sponsor
at
trash betterhelp.com
join over one million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
again that's better help h-e-l-p dot com
slash trash tuesday i don't think we'd
all be here without this
service we certainly would not be in
here together
have you heard of tretin
owen
i think what you're trying to say is
tret's annoying which unclogs pores and
even skin tone
yep
beer and no
which targets hormonal acne ester
clindamisin tendamycin is an antibiotic
that fights acne causing bacteria and
inflammation annie okay i didn't know
what these were until i got my own
prescription acne treatment from
apostrophe the sponsor of this episode
oh yeah apostrophe is a prescription
skincare company that offers
science-backed oral and topical
medications that are clinically proven
to help clear acne apostrophe connects
you with a board-certified dermatologist
who will create a personalized treatment
plan that is perfectly tailored to your
unique skin simply fill out apostrophe's
online quiz about your skin goals and
medical history then snap a few selfies
and your dermatologist will create your
customized treatment plan apostrophe
treats all types of acne too from
hormonal acne to facial acne and even
sisney chesney oh
i know you have butt acne i have chests
did i have that's no i'm just kidding i
might have i for sure have all three i
have the trifecta
i have back knee i have chest knee and i
have um buttony every once in a while i
get one here and there apostrophe has
been clearing it up for me what a
freaking dream this is right i know do
you have a dermatologist at your
disposal this easily yeah because i was
gonna have to go get one of those butt
um facials i what i really like about
this experience in using the service is
that it's nice to know you had an actual
real dermatologist that and that your
plan was tailored by someone who knows
what they're actually talking about i'm
curious what are some of your guys's
skincare goals mine is definitely
reducing dark spots uh reducing redness
improving texture
my back knee
my actually my goals are for you too
i look at you more than i look at myself
i have a lot of hormonal stuff happening
like i have like melasma like darkening
in some parts of my face and i have
eczema and all you have to do is tell
your dermatologist that apostrophe about
it you guys we have a special deal for
our audience save 15 off your first
visit with an apostrophe provider at
apostrophe.com tuesday when you use our
code tuesday this code is only available
to our listeners and to get started just
go to apostrophe.com tuesday and click
begin visit then use our code tuesday at
sign up and you'll get your first visit
for only five dollars
that's a-p-o-s-t-r-o-p-h-e-com
tuesday and use that code tuesday to get
your dermatologist crafted treatment
plan for five dollars are you kidding me
and we thank apostrophe for sponsoring
this podcast honestly if you've had any
skin issues now is the time this is the
most convenient easiest way to go about
helping yourself
all right here we go i'm gonna take mine
in my mouth esther take yours what if it
comes out duty colored it's fine it's
normal that's embarrassing do you want
me oral or anal
you want me to do you anal right now
yeah okay here you can use mine oh i'm
going to feel left out if you so she'll
do it to you too okay
she's nervous oh my god what are you
nuts or do you want to go missionary
you want to go missionary we can do
missionary no no i don't want okay
missionary is actually the funniest
thing i've ever heard
please but
[Laughter]
we should name it oh my god we should
name it diaper girls
oh my god pete's closing his eyes oh my
god
don't you dare get her get her i can't
do this if you're screaming like that
because it feels like rape
okay so
right now for the home audience esther
is getting
her anus penetrated
oh my god you're looking at it i know
what if my hammers are oh my god donut
okay i'm taking the temperature now i
don't think it's in really that much oh
my god that's so sad you have a loose
butthole
oh my god elsa you have a fever
[Laughter]
100.2 not 102. no it's a hundred point
two oh we got the first contender do you
feel good i've been feeling my ass is
gonna go quite cold on this one oh my
god i'm okay i want everyone to see that
esther has not pulled the pants up yet
it didn't feel like anything it didn't
hurt it didn't feel good it was a lube
did you look at my butthole it looks
great a great [ __ ] really oh no
she's not going to say it to me do you
have hemis maybe that's something i'll
let you know if you have him no i can't
believe my podcast i don't want to know
it's just looked at my butthole dave is
going to kill me it doesn't register to
me i know you're a nurse yeah okay you
should put your ring up there and then
when dave's like where's your you lost
your ring you're like come find it and
then he's gotta go fish it up annie are
you gonna let me
sure you have to do you have a home to
side part my ass choose a different
position though cause you can't you
can't do amazon style like she did why
was it too offensive for you no i just a
little harder to find the can we just
spread when she's putting it in my eyes
ask her take her heart
we should have got alcohol wipes wait i
want to do handies yeah you do annie's
no esther's gonna like play with my
label she's gonna start nipping at my
vagina no it's probably better if kalila
does it i'm too nervous
unless you beg for it
sure i feel like you would have fun here
i'll show you come here can i i want to
watch no oh my god
[Laughter]
um you have to find the [ __ ] tell me
where i should wait i feel like and your
ass is amazing
[ __ ] hold on i gotta have my cowboy hat
on okay
i can't agree
i can't quit you
you guys are so much hair
there's no hair there's no hair you have
a most amazing ass honestly your ass
looks hot as [ __ ] yeah esther you don't
try to backpedal [ __ ]
no you do have a big fluffy nice ass
it's not in
oh let's see there it is
[Laughter]
you gotta rotate it spin it 100 flat
esther you're hotter
all right kalila you're one chance at
redemption i am not i'm not trusting
these [ __ ] with my [ __ ] at all
take it regularly [ __ ] awesome
no annie you have a nice ass it's kind
of a bubble butt like both of you guys
have fevered [ __ ]
how did it feel annie
it felt good i felt ashamed i felt like
wait i didn't really feel anything like
a class of [ __ ]
it's like when you go if you go to the
hospital they're like do you mind if
like the students watch it's like no i
don't want the students watching
my anal surgery
i'm just gonna go ahead and say annie
you have a phenomenal ass thank you so
much as the bottle's a little the butter
hole is perfect it's a beautiful [ __ ]
anal bleaching
wait i i love my dark color down there i
gotta i gotta go home bring your belly
masturbate me know [ __ ]
well good thing we got you the most
[ __ ] looking
treat to eat in front of everyone right
now
oh my god she's the one that licks the
wasabi off i take back everything good i
said about today should we um is this
our banana break today
[Music]
all right i like that kaleido's not
washing her hands i should wash my hands
yeah [ __ ] scissor bros do that
honestly they probably have
delilah hey says it bros unless you're
shoving [ __ ] up your ass you ain't got
nothing nothing on these girls 99 chance
they've already shoved things up their
ass on their show
you know what knowing stevie weeby i
think people in the world who would have
shot things
unless there's full penetration
somewhere
oh my god
you are so cute you get nothing
something
interesting happened in the bathroom i
found something in there those are my
sunglasses
you buy 400 sunglasses and you leave
them on the toilet who cares i have tons
of them
[Laughter]
who's having a better life
where should i put them i don't wanna
she doesn't want the responsibility
anymore
it's too stressful
i want to say that was really fun um
three of us driving in the rain like
that i don't know and you're a great
driver it was fun to drive to drive you
guys i drive slow esther's like we're
speeding down the high we're like i'm
like we're going under the speed limit
you know i drive slow when i'm high i do
think doing activities together is
really fun but we need someone to film
george carlos hawaii and yeah carlos ed
yeah is carlos going to come to hawaii
or do we not need him
we don't need him
i want carlos oh my god carlos does not
get to come to hawaii hi annie decides
if he wants to pay for all that he can
pay for the private jet
and we'll let him know how it is is this
the one that this didn't go up either of
your [ __ ] right no that's i have
mine protected nitrated okay i switched
them
i think you should do mouth and then ass
i should have asked then mouth oh yeah
i would love to eat my own ass dude we
got to go to hot yoga
wait first of all can you say i would
love to eat my own ass yeah
well we all have so much in common what
would you do honestly there's nothing
that's going to make me come faster than
if a guy has me like on all fours and he
does a trifecta so it's ass
[ __ ] and then [ __ ] hole
if he doesn't try his tongue or he's
going to get like pressure on the
[ __ ] yeah it's sort of like a
i don't know
but as long as all things are being
handled back there in the line
i just want to let you guys know i know
that i have a new stain on my shirt i
just want to know one of my patients had
a gi bleed
and i really it's part of the job
it does smell good i'm pretty sure part
of the job is keeping your clothes clean
[Laughter]
can't help it i was so in the moment of
saving a life i wasn't thinking super
superficially were you eating their ass
and then it squirted out i well i tried
to stop it started squirting out i tried
to stop it with my mouth wait i just
realized exactly what you look like you
look like a nurse in a porn
that's a hundred percent what you look
like right now and you think it now not
when i was on all fours and you were
staring at my [ __ ]
not the mower like she was spreading and
you were gazing into my butthole
this is the time
it's the eyelashes and the earrings no
the eye you do wake up full porn star
with loose eyelashes it's cool
you know what both of you guys have very
squeaky clean [ __ ] i gotta say i'm
really sort of impressed
you're just doing that for the ratings
no the ratings would be better well
esther i don't like you saying that
after you or the other person seeing my
[ __ ] nobody else saw yours
i can guess that she had to like pull
apart some duty
no some dingleberry no i didn't see did
she go around the dinglebear or she go
through it i didn't get to see in did
you look in for her yeah i didn't really
see because i didn't have a good view so
good i was trying to
yeah you didn't want me looking no
because she's not gonna sexualize me
you're shy huh
a little bit i kind of am i really don't
want to show the inside
of my [ __ ] to you you're just shy you
know too much
she's so much info me she has a whole
dossier she has a whole
sugarfish box filled with information
about me binders and binders do you have
a quiz for us george um yes i do what
are the consequences kalila we didn't do
anything
vaginally vaginally
that's the punishment is we don't get to
do anything vaginally to her
we don't get to stick one up our ass as
the punishment
i can tell you a prize would be
excuse me twice
put a thermometer in your butt would be
a good prize
that feels like a punishment to me
because you i i i need someone to be
very like practical and neutral when
they
um inspect me no you don't [ __ ] i would
yeah i would try my best 20 people that
have tasted your [ __ ] since this show
started i know
oh i'm sorry someone's gonna be doing
the trifecta i'm just trying to get the
[ __ ] thing she's fingering your ass
putting pressure i i you know i was like
it's clear nobody needs to [ __ ] for the
[ __ ] measurements i'd i do be
throwing that ass in a circle to just
about anybody
it's like the only cherries you have
around your ears
you haven't had your ass cherry since
[ __ ] middle school i remember before
my colonoscopy they were like do you
have um anal sex frequently
and i was like
sadly i do wait they asked you that they
don't ask that you know because what
happened when they got the results and
stuff and because i have proctitis
tmi but i have proctitis so i have like
i have some bleeding and stuff like that
i have issues down there that's um the
proximity of a tight ass proctitis
and so there's inflammation in like the
end of my colon and i think it's from
too much aspect wait really yeah so my
doctor was like you know two things it
could be something fleeting is this my
doctor too
no no i have um dr teddy remember wait
her okay she got me this doctor this
like he's such a sweet he's a sweet nice
man he comes in and they're like it was
my first time having health insurance
for so long that he was like
they like talked to me into like a pap
smear and all this stuff and he like
came in and he goes so we're doing a
pelvic exam
uh should we get to know each other a
little bit first it was so funny it was
so awkward wait i could not handle that
i was already in starbucks when he
walked in i could not handle a pelvic
example he might be [ __ ] first
especially if i i respect that it sounds
like a great guy but just being because
you're not attracted to them no no
loosen you up making a joke about like
it just makes me cringe i'd be like i
can't do this i don't even think he was
making a joke i think he was being dead
serious like do you want to like chat
first yeah he was being very super
professional about that because he
looked at your vagina yes dude this
doctor is like the best in town he's
bobby's doctor too but bobby pulls his
pants down so fast and just spreads them
for dr k very fast so funny not a
thought i i just i'm women i'm a team
female gynecologist i'm a team anybody
who is going to do their job right
i respect you for that i want you to
massage therapists now i want unless i
don't but you know what i mean unless
i'm like
like todd watch out if i'm like yeah he
gave me this massage and i was like
[Laughter]
yeah only female masseuse is for me
esther here's your chance to prove
whether or not you okay have your
nursing chops great i'm ready it already
doesn't
okay esther think about this one
a patient's blood sugar is at 60. how
much insulin do you give
a 100 units
six units
two units or none okay i don't know what
a normal blood sugar is and i don't know
how much insulin
you give so i'm gonna guess
i personally am going to choose none
because i don't know the answer but
that's your reasoning do you know what
insulin i'm gonna say yes i know it's
what you give people who have diabetes
it helps their balance their blood sugar
in what direction but i think success is
good so you don't want to give them you
it raises their blood sugar no it lowers
it opposite
it lowers it
so we need for 60 we're gonna need six
units because we're gonna get done 10
points each when i was each time fourth
grade i was in a commercial for
juvenile diabetes donations for
walgreens and only aired in texas
um
i choose none you do look like a like a
14 year old with diabetes all right
kalylah the correct answer is none
whoa because a person already has low
blood sugar
you wouldn't drop them that's not true
because with the blood sugar you need
that no
instincts it's called
instincts for
the the field all right esther you have
to go she's the natural
here we go a patient's heart rate is at
160 beats per minute at resting
is she
tachycardic bradycardic normal or dead
okay
she's not
dead
and she's not normal because that feels
really high
now i'm just trying to think the
prefixes of taw and bra
both
have to do with titties
tachycardia or bradycardia tuck or brady
which one of those would mean
can you say these again
i need to hear you pronouncing
bradycardia or what or tachycardia say
it again tacky or breathing no full one
tachycardia what's the other one
bradycardia tachycardia
[ __ ] i'll just say brady because it's
the one that annie didn't do the correct
answer is tachycardia bradycardia is too
low i study the behavior of people
asking us questions
okay where would i be where would we all
be without adam and eve esther dude are
you kidding me miserable [ __ ] begging
we would be out there begging begging
for help somebody does anybody have a
shaky hand they could lend adam and eve
is the number one trusted source
for adult toys and honestly if you
listen to this show you know you need
some new adult toys okay
annie's all into you know is he's really
into the [ __ ]
i mean it's so is that a harsh to say oh
it's so fun though when the little air
thing pulls out it's literally exciting
i just like the fact that you can
there's a place online that you can it
is it is adult toys it's like going to
toys r us here's why adam and eve is so
[ __ ] cool they've been around for 50
years we've been in the business of
keeping people happy for 50 years and
they have 24 7 customer support 90 day
no hassle returns and discreet packaging
okay so if you don't want your fiance to
see what you ordered no problem i do i
want mine to be tagged exactly and adam
and eve yes and i also feel like i like
that it's called adam and eve because it
is a communal thing it's for both men
and women they have toys for everyone
and i do think such a fun thing about
being in a relationship is like picking
out toys with your partner
and then when you're not in a
relationship picking out your partner
in this show we love
exploring everything there is to know
about sex and adam and eve
has everything you could possibly want a
need in the bedroom i i don't know what
other brand or sponsor we have that
embodies the spirit of this show more
than adam and eve like i feel like if
you enjoy this podcast do yourself a
favor you deserve it and visit
adamandeve.com and use code tuesday for
50 off one item plus free shipping in
the us and canada some exclusions apply
but again visit adam and eve dot com and
use code tuesday for 50 off one item
plus free shipping in the us and canada
and you know what's amazing 20 of the
profits go to help fight the spread of
hiv around the world
go to adamandeve.com use the code
tuesday for 50 off one item and free
shipping in the us and canada and think
about kalila annie and esther when you
do it pleasure princesses think about
your three pleasure princesses all right
guys i actually think that we should
start doing something where when you
order from adam and eve get your toy
comment below tell us what you got and
give it your uh oh and if you love it
please drop me a dm yeah tell us tell us
what you got and tell us if we should
try it we will and we'll try it we can
do reviews
anyone who drinks wine knows that the
options are limitless which is why
finding a wine that you like can be hit
or miss
i didn't know a lot about wine at first
i just know i just knew i just knew what
i liked and what i didn't like and i
couldn't really explain it but firstly
sort of takes out the guesting work
first leaf is a wine club that curates
and ships wines that are perfect
just for you it's like a someone yeah
it's amazing and since they work with
renowned winemakers all over the world
there's virtually no limit to the
variety of wines you get to try not only
does first leaf introduce you to a ton
of new wine each box gets better i'm not
even kidding when you rate the wine you
receive first leaf learns more about
your palette here's a fun little
not-so-secret about first leaf they work
directly with wine makers which means
you get incredible wine 60 off retail
and first leaf is so confident you'll
love the wine they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee if you receive a
bottle that isn't exactly what you were
hoping for firstly will credit your
account dave has been using it and dave
is loving first leaf it's a great
present to get people too i got my
sister around the holidays yeah that's
what an amazing gift to give people it
takes out all the guesswork of wines and
you guys can join today and you'll get
six bottles of wine for 29.95 and free
shipping just go to tryfirsleep.com
tuesday that's six bottles of wine for
29.95 and free shipping at try
firstleaf.com
tuesday
all right annie answers first on the
next one all right how many chambers are
there in a human heart
eight sixteen four or zero depends who
we're talking about you're correct some
people have abnormalities but and a
healthy human heart i think i know the
answer
and he's not looking good
not looking good for annie
there's like mays will be fish swimming
in my head right now
i see i'm seeing them like
i started thinking about my tv has like
a screen saver where these fish like
float around yeah that's what i like
ah the fish
just throwing an answer
zero
okay
okay i'm i'm pretty sure i think that
it's four
okay esther you got it right ding ding
ding why did you think that because i
just remember that from this thing
called school
sorry i was getting molested
all right esther goes first on the final
question i just picked the number of
books they made me reading cards here
i'm in high school what position is this
show the picture george
what do we call this position in nursing
it's very a supine two fowler three
prone or four
face down ass up that's the way we like
to [ __ ]
i like these feet they should be covered
though
these hands can you blur out this for
feed please george i think i know the
answer
i think it's prone
okay but it's technically also face down
ass up that's the way we like to [ __ ] it
is that too yes but i think it's well
you would be such a good cheerleader
why just the way you said that was so
peppy annie what's your answer mine is a
supply pine because her
spine is
chilling that would have been my second
guess i wish it could be but the correct
answer is prone
so i remember that because
you're prone to disease yeah
yeah because in covid they were putting
people on the ventilators like face up
but then they were so glad then they
started to put them face down because
they realize that was better i am so
glad i don't know that information
i steered so clear from that [ __ ]
news i was like oh please i do not want
to know which direction they have the
patience facing
i'm gonna opt out of that
one all right as the winner esther
you'll find a medical device next to you
on your table okay it says use it as
best possible oh that's a fun one where
what part of the body does that so this
is the reflex hitter okay and it goes on
it goes up annie's ass now you have my
prostate find my prostate
here should i can you make it happen do
you know where exactly to hit i think i
do it's okay i'll forget it's gonna be
in between it's gonna be between the big
knobby part here and then the second
knobby so it's going to be right in
between but you have to be in a correct
position and you cross your legs like
this
everyone's always saying that cross your
legs
remember pete
last week i was like you think i have my
period it's ready i don't want to be
here to cross her legs guys i have
really thickened up i'm working with
this trainer and they're not going to
get skinnier i'm making sure they stay
this thick to get my chair exchanged you
know how embarrassing that is they'd get
an inside chair and bring it outside i
was like my ass hurts so [ __ ] bad but
your body is high it's like you have
like the kardashian like ass and thighs
i gained weight
in your ass all the right places yeah
but my arms and my
shoulders here i don't think it i'll
show you exactly can't get it here are
the two points oh yeah that's right so
between these two points here uh-huh
that's not hard she's not
um they're not they're both dead they're
not none of them my legs i'm not
the shortest person in the world where
my feet dangle
so
hear hear pass it to me can you do it on
yourself yeah really so it's going to be
right here
oh there we go
i don't know why it makes me cringe
really yeah because you're okay wait
that's so funny that uh because that's
your leg being out of control no it's
like it's just funny that i want to be a
nurse but that makes me cry it's just
like not going well the way you handled
the ass stuff though i think you could
you could figure it out i have to be a
proctologist i think so i think you
could probably get down with some really
gory stuff and i think like the least
you'd probably such horseshit i could
it's just that like makes my shoulders
the smell of a like the beautiful smell
of like a fire and like a fireplace
makes her like
suicidal she's not going to be okay with
the smell of like i'm not really
bleeding i'm not really squeamish but
the smells are huge in hospital no but
when i know what it is and what i'm
dealing with
did i get to use mine uh yes annie as uh
the second place in the uh quiz you have
vandalise as well oh my god get that
[ __ ] thing away oh [ __ ] come here
would you let kalila do it i hate that
so much it doesn't matter it's a
speculum
and it's what the [ __ ]
it's
would you eat a spider or let me put
this in living spider put that in
and then i let put the spider inside
then you have a half spider baby it's
got something well esther you would have
cute little spider bees it would be a
girl be spider girl what are you saying
yeah spider girl oh my god this is a new
movie idea okay fine let's do it
who's getting the duck bill no i'm not
no one is no
vagina has been exposed so many times
today for you to act like this is like a
crazy request are you willing to get it
in there
i
i'm on wax she just got waxed you're
right i could just show you my wax [ __ ]
and without having that thing up in me
i could just show you what my [ __ ] looks
like
i want to see your cervix [ __ ]
i want to be like there she is okay
all right oh
a little expanded
out i'm banged out i am banged up it's
got a cholo it says it's someone
actually tagged it
in there
puppet
and nut just written across a nut puppet
not it says nut puppet nut pup fan art
please it says slept king was here
bobby's actually inside you
he didn't go to he didn't go to new york
esther you had um
asked me um
earlier today if i believed in
manifestation do you
um she was like you go first
[Laughter]
well okay i was watching this video by
ashley graham on youtube she's the
plus-size model it's illustrated i know
this sounds crazy but she made it a
video just explaining manifesting and
she actually explained it like for the
first time i feel like i heard it in a
way that i
i see it
she needs to be from a model a female
hot girl
but like i always used to think of
manifesting as like this like
magical spiritual
um
made up thing that like only people who
like have crystals are into
but now i've learned that manifesting
is just the word it's it's not as like
freaky as it sounds but it's really just
like if you want something you think
about it and you put it out there by
saying by telling people and by having
it on a vision board and i do believe
that that works i'm just curious do i
sound crazy or do you guys agree oh it's
so crazy oh yeah like i've been talking
about you get you i tell me i'm a psycho
all the time i think we manifested this
podcast uh yeah no i was telling you
that too like where it's like it's it
like i think it's all about
really like believing you can have stuff
if you don't believe you can have stuff
and the thing like you want things but
you don't feel like you could you
deserve them or whatever you can't get
them i just i think about it's easy when
you talk in specifics right so like i
think about this podcast and how
for years annie and i had talked about
wanting to do a podcast but we never
quite
figured it out
the right way whatever and it wasn't
until you came along where we obviously
all knew all three of us knew it once oh
my god that's it but i don't think we
would have gotten here without the years
of talking about it thinking about it
you mentioned it
the 12 years of open mic for this
podcast and even though that seems like
super basic and
not that exciting i still just think
that talking about the things you want
and picturing them like for me i just i
really stand by that and i feel like it
actually works and i i've taken the like
hocus pocus out of it and it's more
practical for me you can just see it as
like a self-fulfilling prophecy really
so it's like if it's something you want
it's something you talked about
something that you think about put in
the forefront of your thoughts it's
something that you're eventually going
to lead yourself to
so i think that's just sort of takes its
natural course yeah yeah if you if you
well it's all like for me the all the
work that i've done it's what made it
make sense for me is like
your it's your subconscious belief
around what you can have like if i'm
thinking i'm like i'm just like poor um
you know i'm never gonna have money i'm
never like i see the world through that
lens if i look at the world like where
i'm like i'm a successful person
and i'm like abundant then i'm now
looking at the world that way i'm not
stressing about things that i was
stressed out about before and now i'm
seeing more opportunities to
create what i want like i think we can
have whatever we want like especially
like if we're [ __ ] professional
comedians like how many people have
wanted to do that or said they want to
do something like that but the reason
that manifesting sort of doesn't hold as
much like water as i think it could in
my life is because i think i know
i've seen instances with like really
really good people with really good
hearts and big dreams and who've had
just a really
unlucky hand at life and it's no matter
what they've manifested either their kid
has cancer or somebody like something
really tragic happens to them and um so
it's that's where i'm kind of like like
maybe it is a chance thing maybe
it's a privileged thing it is a chance
and it is a privileged thing that's for
sure it really is and in fact like it's
i think when people talk about
manifesting it
turns a lot of people off and it used to
turn me off too
and what if we caught a woman
but you're totally right like it's
absolutely a privileged thing and it
kind of is like some people are just in
careers especially where like
that doesn't really even make sense well
right it's it's easy to manifest
something if you already have the upper
hand like yeah but it's also like what
you choose too right like what you
choose to pursue and
i often think about how my life could
have gone completely different way
because at seven i was supposed to go to
school in switzerland because my dad's
sister lived there she had a family
there and my sister and i were supposed
to just
live in europe right
and i would have never met you guys i
would have never been an island bumpkin
first maybe you would have yes who knows
i would have might found my way to you
eventually maybe well yeah i i believe
that who was i i just said this to my to
one of my friends
who was like oh like that's how we met
and i'm like i actually believe that we
would have met and i thought that way
about dave too because i met dave at a
party but i'm always like no i would
have met him if i didn't go to that
party but some people think that that's
not true but i believe like
i don't know oh i don't maybe it's my
denial i just don't want him i don't
know the world where i wouldn't have met
you i don't believe in fate at all i
don't believe in fate either i believe
in like
random beautiful occurrences and i
believe while this path is good for me
and i'm happy to have met you that the
alternate path would have been okay as
well i feel like i will have an amazing
life no matter what happens exactly and
like sounds like kalila prefers the
other path
like it's she's like yeah it's nice she
did kind of like let us down
yeah
do you feel like at all that you
manifested this podcast or do you think
that you just it like they're bits and
pieces of my life where i'm like holy
[ __ ] like this kind of come full circle
where it's like i thought about that
and it happened but i think that's also
just sort of like setting my sights
there and then reaching it it's just
weird because what always ends up
happening to me is i
set a goal i either write it down or i
have like a vision like in my ayahuasca
trip about this podcast and then i'm
living it and then i go oh my god like i
[ __ ] asked for this like i don't
realize it until i'm like
really kind of like in the present
moment of it
because that i forgot that i was
literally on ayahuasca vomiting into a
bucket imagining powerpuff girls like
two other girls yeah like i it's so
weird the one thing i will say when we
first started tiger belly is that i gave
myself no option when i started it i was
like
i'm not gonna stop and this is gonna be
something and those are i didn't know
what it was gonna be but those are the
two truths that i i knew for sure i had
to follow through with that i'm not
gonna stop and it's gonna be something
whatever that something was i didn't
know that fulfills my definition of
manifesting i think yeah because you set
you told yourself this is what it's
gonna be yeah and then you made it
happen and then if you believe it like
in manifestation i feel like the
the key that always helps me is like
you feel yourself having the thing
already and then you carry yourself and
you operate in life yeah you have it and
it just like is it's sort of the seed
that you already planted in there
without knowing that you planted in
there yeah even if you think about it so
your body autopilots its way there can i
can i make a pitch here and you tell me
if if you think this counts as
manifesting and if it's like privileged
because i'm trying since you called it
privilege i'm trying to think of like a
way for it to be more accessible like
let's say you work at a bank
and but you really you have this craft
that you love doing it could be like
making miniature things or like making
candles whatever it is and you're
passionate about it like does esther
think she's inventing etsy no it's so
sad that's just like and then we can
name it like
i'm about to say
let let's say you were like i want to
have my own etsy store on the side where
i sell my candles and so what i would
say if if i knew you wanted that i'd
like to manifest that
start telling people that you're gonna
do it and that you want to do it and you
say it in a positive present tense like
it's already happening rather than
because if you're insecure about it
other people aren't gonna and don't
don't downplay yourself either even if
you're not sure
just say hey i have this idea and people
will always try to shoot it down but
hold yourself but there's also going to
be people who are like really that's so
cool you should check out this and they
might point you in different right
directions because they people want to
help each other and then
also
you're gonna if you say it to yourself
let's say you wrote it on a piece of
paper and you stuck it on your bathroom
wall or whatever mirror then you might
remember oh i want to research more
today about how to do this like
that to me is what manifesting is does
that that's not privilege it might be i
know it isn't a way because if your kid
has cancer you don't have time to do
that but yeah i don't know
i hate that the kid having cancer part
came into this well
[ __ ] that's your co-host
and now it's like now we're like that's
the co-host now we're like yelling at a
dying baby like [ __ ] you i got uh
expensive sunglasses because i believed
yeah wear your sunglasses dying kid
like why is that to be that because my
mom was a hospital you played with it
too you were like because you she
challenged me because we're gonna get
hashtag privilege now yeah
i mean it is true guys it's like i agree
i mean i agree like if you're in like if
you're
i'm gonna i can't there's nothing to do
i'd like to broach this topic with my
cousin in the philippines who lives in
poverty
if you're in america and you bought the
book the secret that you can manifest
things into yours no but seriously no if
you're if there's so many opportunities
online for people like i think that like
this younger generation below us too is
like
people are making money doing very
little like they're figuring out like
weird hustles first of all for sure
manifestation is very much a possibility
for sure in first world setting yeah
given that nothing tragic has happened
to your life that's so out of your
control that you don't even have time to
think the truth is that there are some
people that that have gotten have
manifested in a [ __ ] incredible life
coming from that too so it's like you
can't like discount everyone but
have you guys ever been in the presence
of a dead body or a morgue
no
but i would be interested
we want to do maybe a ride along with a
nurse yeah no i want to i've always
wanted to go
ride along with an ambulance
i've always wanted to go to one of the
schools where they the cadavers yeah
they had that in um
no i why does that happen
they put on they're like morgue people
yeah they're morticians right they
didn't see it you know i saw it i just
don't i don't remember the movies i saw
like
before this year veda
i know no one's going to believe this
and everyone's going to make fun of me
but there was a period in my life where
i thought i wanted to be a forensic
scientist wait that's amazing you know
what i want to watch forensic files i
didn't watch forensic files wait do you
watch i've never seen
i don't know what i saw you know you
don't want to be a forensic anything if
you don't know who dr boden is i don't
you scream when you see spider like what
are you talking about spiders are not
dead bodies annie you may propose
something about bodies that the spiders
make you scream they're not
it's different may i propose something
they're less than a human that's
i'm sorry spiders cancel me now okay
i feel better than you spiders
i want to propose something what about a
forensic entomologist what's that so
basically you are going to age someone's
death you're going to date it this
person has been dead for eight days they
use it a lot in like i'm always so
curious how do they do that based on the
insects that are living in their bodies
so there's a body farm in indiana that
you can learn all of this stuff yeah no
let's send her to the body farm so it's
basically no no no let's do a body farm
episode i will cancel hawaii i want to
see esther totally cool with the larva
inside of a dead body yes and depending
on that maggot stage the stage of where
the maggot is at is basically how you
know how do they look in how do they
find it that's entomologist is a person
who um studies insects so it's basically
an insect biologist right she gotcha but
you can put those two things together
that you love dead bodies and insects
so what do they do they like cut into
the skin and then they see what bugs
yeah they do it a lot with like people
they don't like john doe's or jane doe's
is that they call him james yeah did you
ever dissect a frog in school okay we're
getting into like a lot of different
areas the frog thing
i don't agree with because you don't
need to kill an animal you can easily
just use a plastic are they already dead
the frogs not always no the ones that we
used to the heart would still be beating
because they wanted us to oh you had to
murder them yeah
it was pretty brutal when i was i think
there's a difference than from killing a
frog for science or just someone is
already dead but whatever living person
that needs your help you would be able
to cut them open and things are still
moving yes i think you would
if i was trying to
should would i do it today no i need the
training also by the way if you said
strain that was like if someone was like
put you in a really stressful situation
if we were to go find like a cadaver
that um they use at schools the blood
would be drained there's nothing gooey
about it it's very like formaldehyde job
is to drain the blood
that's what the job i want your job
that's a i think that's a mortician's
job right the drain the blood right out
right george
but my mom was a hospice nurse so would
she wanted to do that she just always
saw people on their way out i like that
yeah my great grandfather ran a funeral
home
i don't that's all i know but you should
dude you know the last episode with
hannah um we talked about we're getting
into the wrong business if we yeah for
money
dude there's a lot death is forever i
know we should get in the business of
death
my favorite accountant because i'm
making great money wait didn't we once
what about like becoming makeup artist
for dead bodies well that's what um an
embalmer does
there's a job you go to school for that
um the embalm is what they always say
duh embalm
um i'll embalm some [ __ ]
we could get around a dead body i would
do that with you guys
i want to experience things
yeah is there a place to take this i was
really interested in that
probably not but they have this show
that they used to put at loma linda
university where they will
have yes the people who have donated
their bodies to science so you can see a
pregnant woman with like her deceased
baby inside her opened up this way
it's it's pretty [ __ ] amazing i would
love it
knows how to really did you guys ever
see the body exhibit
did you ever see the bodies exhibit
which is featured in casino royale yes
oh i love that yeah did you see it yeah
my dad took me to church years ago
the mutter museum where they have like
shellacked
things
do they have come well it's all it's all
the medical monstrosities is in
philadelphia
so they have yeah and they have like
they have a file cabinet of all things
they found inside people's stomachs that
they'd swallowed like all these weird
toys and like you know you should have
on the show is um do you follow um mrs
angeli no who's that she is a forensic
pathologist but she has a massive
following she has this thing called the
gross room where she explains how people
die because she has to basically figure
out like she gets everything from like
a stillborn to somebody
who
you know got their dick hatchet off you
know like she sees it all right
um but we should have her on the show
cool yeah do you know i feel like she
would be is it you it feels yes it's me
i only study the hatchet penises though
i've had to cut them off myself
do you think you could ever hate someone
enough to hatch at their penis no no
i don't hate people i just don't vibe
with them anymore
i really i think i've eliminated the
hate
yeah i don't even hate like my teacher
that did that [ __ ] like i'm just like
whatever he's like not a good dude but
i hate him because you won't shut up
about it
[Laughter]
dude okay now esther does your ball hang
lower on this side
i think one ball's supposed to hang
lower than the other george george can
we see your ball
george no this isn't that type of show
guys but yes
it's actually uh medically on purpose so
that you can run george is your penis
smaller bigger than this
i don't even know i can't see what
you're saying but let's go with bigger
[Laughter]
actual size ester this reminds me of
your vagina that's my penis i'm sorry i
was giving good medical uh knowledge
like the balls are different sizes so
that you could run so they don't clap
into each other when you're running
and now esther how wide would the tape
have to be on hand
mine would be about out here
these are tiny little uh
did you guys watch sex in the city
growing up was that like your generation
i did yes i watched it with my parents i
was never team big i was always aiden
okay big was sucked aidan was awesome
aiden was a great in my life i'm like
big is but you want just some of this
you want money they they take you places
you do stuff you got the guy but aidan
didn't not have money but aiden wasn't
her guy she didn't feel it he was too
soft for her at a time where she didn't
i did i do understand that yeah i when i
watch i first of all i didn't watch it
because my parents watched it so i like
hid when they were watching it but then
when i got when i was 18 did you watch
them through a thing watching it
sometimes
i
paige
through like the bars that are upstairs
um i
watched it when i got my wisdom teeth
out like i because you know whatever i
was just binging it like i written to
the libraries from the dvd for while i
was healing
i think sex in the city sends like a
really weird message that made me feel
bad which is it made me it's for some
reason it landed on me like you need to
find hurry up and find a man before you
get old and you like cause these [ __ ]
are having such a bad time well that's
like i feel like they talk to i feel
like they explicitly said like i'm
getting older i need to settle down like
and i think that's such a bad message
and it made me feel like [ __ ]
yeah i just thought it had so so much
good stuff it was so cool it was so like
different personalities different
experiences different types of dudes
that i'm like oh yeah i've met a guy
like that
it was really i thought it was really
entertaining um
you know they took weird fashion choices
it was just really yeah that was fun so
many like levels i just thought it was
so
fun and you saw yourself like i i did a
thing for people magazine where they
were like our tv i don't know what it is
but um
we were talking about it and they said
that i think that one of the theories is
that it's one woman and all four of
those are her
different characteristics different
parts of her yeah
that sounds
that to me
is an argument against the show right
because it's like so then each woman is
just an archetype or one corner of you
why can't each woman be a full woman of
with like
and i i get it it's tv it has to be this
way but maybe it doesn't why does there
have to be the [ __ ] one why like why
can't i i don't know also
ruining our show
[Laughter]
we are kind of like we each have i think
oh our show yeah like it's kind of like
i see i disagree i think we're all
[ __ ]
yes i think we're all poor yes
i think we're all rotten we're from old
sperm yeah
open wide esther hey esther pete has a
final piece of uh medicine since it's
the medical uh episode it's a gift oh
chug it
chug it butt chug it
put up your house you drink it [ __ ] do
you want me to and then i'll drive you
something what is that esther steak oil
it's dayquil severe
wow acetamino acetaminophen for pain
here i'll be the nurse a cinnamon open
for pain
guava fenesene
ma'am you're done in here
there's a person about to die that's for
life getting the mucus out draining of
from where
nose mouth throat lungs chesty cough
it's a
expectorant yeah phenyl ferrin which i
think is benadryl i don't know what hcl
is oh no that's attached to
phenylethyrene
dextromethorphan hbr which one gets you
high oh literally it says basically all
of that on the package i was just
looking at the i just want to say you
can't be my nurse you can't be my
pharmacist you can't be the businessman
that leads me to the pharmacy
i don't trust you you get nowhere near
me
can i control your finances
that i will let you down
i just want you to see how much money i
have i should cry
oh there's so much let's see if
manifestation works let's like write it
down on a piece of paper how much you're
going to make next year yeah i just want
to make sure i make more than that
cancer baby
guys i want to let you know it is a
direct competition
what would you manifest for next year
you already know i've written it down to
you that's how i've manifested it okay
yeah
but we already did it you saw both of
our [ __ ] what now yeah god i reached
the peak of my life just [ __ ] let me
jump off the cliff now
something's happening to kaleilas why
what's happening to me what do you mean
she's just like yeah that was the
coolest moment of my life seeing her
[ __ ] where it's like i feel like
back in the day when she thought her
shoulders were broad
she was like more into my shoulders are
broad
no i think you're starting to catch on
that you're
way hotter than that you know you guys
are rubbing off on me can i tell you how
you guys are rubbing off on me never in
my life have you ever rubbed off on you
[ __ ] considered getting gel x or
[ __ ] dip powder nails now look at me
now that looks so what made you do it
you wanted to feel like i saw your
yeah you know i was like wait am i that
girl am i that girl and then i did it
once and then i couldn't do it a second
time
i felt
i moved differently with them on you
don't want them again
i want them again i like it it's
click-clap key it's things it's like a
thing it's fun the only thing is i feel
like um so i'm still getting used to
them but i feel like i can't do as much
i can't open little things it gets in
the way of fine motion you'll learn you
have jewels for that that's true my
mommy and mama mama
i'm a little irritated that bobby's out
of town and dave's out of town you
haven't invited
us over for a sleepover well she has 27
vicious dogs
at her house at all times it's like
between her and whitney i don't know how
anyone comes out i'm punctured ever i'm
so glad because i i look at whitney i'm
like but she has a lot of money and
probably a lot of help right in this zoo
operation here it really just is jules
and i so we're running around we're
always thinking about the dogs no matter
what we do it's like what about the dogs
more than that
it's her and like one other person who's
or two other people
but it's that our dogs are our life my
animals are my life there's really
little time for anything else yeah
well that's how miranda is she has six
animals she's like you
and that's all doesn't she find more a
lot too yeah she's a collector like you
every week isn't there a different dog
in this room there's a different dog
that might um attack us while we go to
pee yeah how many dogs have been in that
room since you've been we had drippy
nipples we had droopy eyes
we didn't have draggy leg and i'm pissed
about that there was a draggy like dog
that that kalila like
gave up her fight for
yeah yeah yeah blood we bloodhead we had
already named it yeah bloodhead and
i just wanna let you guys know that we
get a sign that says rap sometimes and
this is the first time i think you've
ever seen it
well it's usually i don't have to
because esther ends it early well
because
i'm the one who sees it and then i try
to end the podcast and then annie starts
like calling me out that i want to end
it but i'm just following jordan george
is injured
the last two episodes i'll give it to
you but when we were outside there was
no sign you have always ended it you're
always cold hot
she's got a heart out we didn't know i'm
comfortable today i'll stay all night
i see you you're in your new
uniform
i want to sleep over i'm going to end by
saying this
you [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm going to end this
by saying this let's sleep over
um i think both of you guys um would
make wonderful nurses because while i
think where you lack in compassion
you make up for with um comedic relief
and spirit spirit
and charm yes does a nurse need this
okay doesn't does a does a hospital need
this is this a candy striper because i
when my friends need to move or
something they invite me over knowing i
will do nothing but entertain them while
they pack into that yes call the
chathams yes that's the thing i'm hatch
atoms yes which by the way should we we
have to call monica uh at some point
remember when i met the woman from
patchat adams oh that's right um the
girl from conair yeah
monica potter monica potter get in there
now kalila if you had to eat one of us
out
or the pockets is over based on you not
what you saw today no but yes based on
what you saw today who would you use an
[ __ ] or
anything
and i okay my first instinct would be
annie but the only reason i would choose
you ultimately is because you're the one
who would enjoy it she would like it
more i would like nervous why would you
choose annie would be the reluctant she
would just be like i'm really not
enjoying this at all
you're [ __ ] lapping her up like a dog
all right the show's over
it would make her so happy though that
would be my charity in this case you are
the dog she is the cat i agree yeah i'm
fine with that i'm confident
i have to earn her [ __ ] i already
have your [ __ ]
all right now i know i have to play the
little laws of power with you
we'll be seeing how things go next week
then
you guys thank you for watching please
like this video please subscribe and
comment for the algorithm we need you we
love you we'll see you guys next week we
manifested you we love you you're in us
goodbye
[Music]
you